read of all evil if you want to point at
it as politicians that are going to save
you and I from terrorists from the
illegal immigrants from drugs elect me
and I'll saved I am Gary Johnson former
governor of new mexico i presume a
presidential candidate here on Wall
Street to visit Occupy Wall Street find
out what it's all about I think we
should go in here with an open mind and
ask questions and see what we can find
out I'm sort of former tea party I never
really got bought out by the you know
the Christian conservatives an educator
I've been on the point for two and a
half years I have two masters degrees
not doing me any good sixty thousand
dollars in student loans when you have
this like this grassroots democratic
movement you get all these different
voices yelling together and you know
sometimes one voice comes up as like the
more powerful voice and the others get
drowned out you know especially when the
billions of dollars came into the Tea
Party movement that's when the more
moderate Scott Brown that and the
Italians got dragged down him and so you
know that's why I've moved on to this
one so I'm Gary Jones oh you're the
political guy and it's kind of unfair
that all of these people running for
office or coming here and trying to
co-opt are
their own political gain I'm not trying
to do that because i have to say there
have been a lot of political groups we
come down and try to garner attention
for themselves but it's really not with
this movement is about i would not think
so yeah this movement is beyond politics
what is the movement about well I can't
speak for everybody here I can tell you
that I think it's about I think it's
about wealth and income inequality and I
think that everybody deserves to have a
government that represents them I'm
against the wars and I'm in my Wars I
mean our military involvement I'm
against the drug war I've been married
what about taxes
I'm advocating throwing out the entire
federal sentence throwing out the entire
federal taxes have been replacing it
with the Fair Tax is it a progressive
tax let's say it's a consumption tax so
you want all of us to pay for everything
we consume even though we don't get the
same rights to consume it what among
other things the Fair Tax does is it
issues everyone in the country a two
hundred dollar-a-month freebase shed
which allows all of us to pay the
fairtax up to the point of the poverty
line I'll tell you a secret I got some
money and I think I should be taxed
yeah money when George Bush decided to
estate tax and I think that is totally
outrageous so I decided to keep twenty
percent for myself and get eighty
percent away but I think that if we rely
on the kindness of strangers that the
poor will keep getting screwed so civil
libertarians don't work for me for the
poor but I think it's very unfocused and
incoherently I guess I think but I think
it should sharpen his goals and it's
necessary so forth you know it's not
enough of what we mean by Walston
anybody who has a lot of money is any
kind of capitalist is it any financial
institution yeah I'm not sure motions
folks to tell you again just anecdotal
conversations tend to tell me that they
don't really have a clear idea of what
the problem is little only solution is
oh are you doing here I'll just check it
out
okay excellent so what do you think
about you take the two elements and
there's much credible happening here as
there is fringe as perhaps there's as
much
credible happening that the Tea Party is
there is I actually totally think that's
a the write it out like you know I know
a lot of people are like hasn't have to
make that analogy but I'm not at office
and I think the tea party since the same
exact thing is these guys which is
pissed man we're tired of not getting
represented
right and so now look there'll be French
in the tea party like you said they'll
be French here right but I think the
core was resonating on both those places
that's got so many people jazzed up is I
we're tired that bounded any boat on
these guys and it never makes a
difference right rather it's
conservative issues or liberal issues it
doesn't matter
not listening what would you say to
occupy us here who are skeptical of
really any politicians and then
that the leaders that we have simply
aren't capable of addressing that kind
of reform that I think this movement
wants what would you say
that they're right on that's exactly the
situation that exists in this country
today but they're rotten through
the root of all evil if you want to
point out it is politicians that are
going to save you an eye from terrorists
from illegal immigrants from drugs elect
me and I'll save
[Music]